hello and welcome to this video I think
after I shut the door okay let's play
deeper Matata and it better be a win
yeah so I really have to get get away
from this this rating here this guy I've
lost two times against and looking at
his opening play now here probably I
lost from very good position because
that looks very strange anyway so we'll
see what happens
he's weakened the d5 square quite a lot
and also lost time in the process maybe
I should have taken immediately on f6 we
might move it the night I mean so let's
do this interesting Momiji iam I don't
know III as an idea I think I'm going to
play it just keepin night out from going
to deform
I could excellent light squares yeah but
he has some space on the kingside so it
will probably play some some active
moves over there I'm not quite sure what
it is because my position looks very
solid what's natural plan is before
which is hard to prevent in the long run
[Music]
I'm not threatening it right away
because III is under under pressure it
move like we need to looks very normal
to cover that yeah something like that I
would probably play yeah this is I
expected after he has played g6 it looks
for how the crude but black has to do
something if he just sits around his
position will be very bad so I wonder
man aged form it's not threatening all
that much I one day the bishop f3 to g4
is actually an idea
I don't think age three is is dangerous
I'm not sure if I wanted flame if I want
to play before he and his position and
open everything my position feels a
little bit unstable after that
[Music]
I don't really see anything for him
though okay well if it takes everything
it takes on e3 takes on everyone
it is not very well coordinated it
really isn't what I can do is I can no I
don't want to do that I was thinking of
taking on on a form
yeah g-form maybe I should do that
cheer form just keep things closed and
that preventing a piece coming to f5
yeah this okay if I take it then he's
got f3 so I probably don't want to do
that I rather want to protect you form
King edge one and so on at least it
feels fairly closed
now feels fairly close
playing a couple of prophylactic mostly
before him doing something substantial
[Music]
so
I don't know if Knight b5 is an idea
threatening nine to seven but it's
probably rather rather naive I don't see
anything yet though if he takes it I
shouldn't remove that you never know hey
take speed three looks very normal but
it looks very embarrassing if they play
something else which one we wouldn't
make sense but you still are the one
looking stupid if you play Ruby three so
what's going on b7 is under pressure
Queen d7 does not be sick so I expect
you have seven or would be eight okay we
can insert the small for sure okay so he
does some desperation stuff what what is
going on and 95 is what he wants to play
and this is the kind of thing that would
work objectively but can be dangerous
for sure so let's see Bishop Jake's Co
Tady f1 take g4
so I take with the night 95 is fairly
active
so what to do
hmm therefore doesn't work I'm not sure
what he's actually threatening takes
takes Bishop g4 I can take FA tech g4
but then I'm chick mated this is this
pawn is extremely limiting him hmm okay
it is more dangerous than I thought
really is time warning not happy about
this but time wasn't good and didn't
didn't see anything really great yeah
this is not bad for him probably g4 is
hanging
[Music]
and this pawn is extremely annoying on
h3 I'm sitting in all kinds of meeting
meeting at the ideas
my take on f3 Queen takes Knight XD 3
this kind of thing you have to take and
now what is he threatening OOP Jim one
white stroke g1 working check it doesn't
work don't see why it's not working
should pick up the night for nothing
much I don't know how to take care I
think I thought I am I'm just attacking
here right 96 so there's no reason to
trade Queens I don't see any any
swindling things here I will just take
g6 next yeah but I teach you five here
right I'm not meted check draw the
lacquer resigned yet Julian enough check
yeah I mean as bad as the opening play
was he had an attack if this kind of
setup is basically unplayable for
Blackie I mean I should probably play
like him
I should probably play d4 I didn't
really take into account that he might
play five which was a good move I should
do this and this kind of central
information is just extremely extremely
bad because it cannot move any pawns now
you can never move the D pawn or the
b-pawn you're just sitting in a very bad
construction and here I thought I'll do
that next move simply and I did not
anticipate this and this is actually
good yeah he's blocking my mighty
formals and now he's got a somewhat
worse structure but it's not it's not
like immediately terrible
get this and okay this should be nice
but he is reasonably actor as you see
the engine at least that is I don't know
what that doesn't give all that much
it's um it's not a clear situation so
yeah does this all looks fairly normal
yeah night with five is interesting
maybe to prevent some bishop moves but
at the end snow I don't want to go there
brookey one is fine I think age five and
I think all those most seem seem logical
oh it's got Bishop g4 here's interesting
because I mean here I have some
compensation as change shows the light
squares will be a very nice but still
it's not not really what I wanted so
Queenie to probably was over cautious
ninety-four is better okay so we should
before then Moses was on yeah he I took
a long while to play g4 I really wasn't
sure that this looks like a position
where there are a couple of options the
engine still likes might be five and I'm
still not sure what it does it prevents
a couple of things there like we should
be six this night or I can't even take a
okay maybe he just place this to cover
up before so that I'm actually
threatening to take this is possible
okay I played G form and he gave the
pawn I cannot take it after f3 and this
is pretty awful so I moved it to f3
Bishop here and now King in the in the
corner to be ready to play book g1 if
necessary and now he played this
you form which I really don't think
should work but it was it was getting
very active for him so and the computer
basically confirms that it doesn't work
oops sorry but this is a different thing
in in a blitz game so where am i
pressing this all the time so it thinks
that this is okay or it calculates
thinks is wrong right f4 so I played
this right
yeah I'm just winning because what what
what can you do here I mean if he takes
with the Queen I'm going to check win
the house here that was but it's sad
that I didn't play d4 earlier but okay I
simply didn't anticipate 65 because this
is really bad yeah I mean here black
will have you trouble okay guys thanks
for watching